[Musik]
Mallorca Ballermann ein Polizist aus
Braunschweig im Einsatz unter Palmen es
ist alles dabei raubdiebstahl
Körperverletzung und Touristen als Opfer
100 Euro
überfallen ausgeraubt Taschen Diebe das
ist eine Mafia hier ein Dienst der ist
in sich hat wir sind hier die
Eingreiftruppe Playa ein deutscher
Beamter im Party Getümmel
[Musik]
El Arenal eine der bekanntesten
Strandpromenaden Europas
hunderttausende Deutsche feiern hier
ihren Sommerurlaub
für drei Wochen schiebt er hier Dienst
Thorsten Obst Polizeibeamte aus
Braunschweig macht sich fertig für den
Tag der 58-Jährige schlüpft in seine
deutsche Uniform Ausrüstung nach
Vorschrift wie zu Hause
und natürlich meine Dienste von
Deutschland aus mitgebracht habe
ein Blick aufs Revier Ballermann 6
schräg voraus zwei Straßen weiter
Schinkenstraße da werden wir präsent
sein heute wieder so
um 14 Uhr fahren die spanischen Kollegen
am Hotel vor mit ihnen verbringt
Thorsten seit 40 Jahren Polizist die
Spätschicht mit dabei der Chef der
Einheit Clemente Paris ihre Mission
Sicherheit am Ballermann
[Musik]
Kontrollgang in der feierzone nach
wenigen Metern der erste bürgerkontakt
für das deutsch-spanische polizei-team
immerhin erkennt er noch die deutsche
Uniform
aber thorsten hat seine Mühe den jungen
Mann zu verstehen
zu viel Nähe der spanische Polizist wird
ungeduldig was machst du denn da mit den
spanischen Kollegahs
der junge Mann will einen Alkoholtest
machen aber der ist völlig überflüssig
auch so ist klar in welchem Zustand er
ist auch ein paar andere sind schon
ziemlich fröhlich
in meiner Bauchtasche und ein Pferd wenn
ich dich aufpassen
40 Grad Hitze die Streife geht weiter
das hier ist die Karriere oder
Schinkenstraße ja je nach Lage gehen wir
hier am Tag etwas weniger abends wenn es
voller wird oder nachts sind wir
natürlich öfter mal unterwegs damit die
Leute auch sehen unterwegs ist Präsenz
und Prävention das ist die Devise der
spanischen polizia national und Sie
haben gerade jetzt viel zu tun die
deutsche Unterstützung ist gern gesehen
so Polizei drin steht nicht drauf
bitte
gar nicht
natürlich bin ich echt bei dem Wetter
verkleide ich mich so oder was willst du
denn aus Niedersachsen hier an wie komme
ich da dran das hier nennt sich
eu-kommissariate gibt immer
Ausschreibung jedes Jahr und dann kann
man sich drauf bewerben
natürlich klar also die spanischen
Kollegen die sprechen einfach Spanisch
aber der deutsche versteht man halt
nicht ne logischerweise und wenn sie
dann auch noch auf dem Kessel haben dann
verstehen hier schon mal gar nichts mehr
und dann macht es natürlich ein bisschen
Sinn wenn man zumindestens mit den
Deutsch sprechen kann auch wenn sie sich
dann auch nur zu 50% verstehen aber das
ist ja schon mal was
so viel Spaß tschüss
ein paar Meter weiter Thorsten Obst
erklärt das Hauptproblem passt auf eure
Handys auf ganz wichtig hier kurze Hose
Holzgewehr die ruckzuck fassen die ich
mal kurz an und dann hast du das Handy
weg ich glaube schon
Taschendiebstahl Raub viele deutsche
Touristen haben das nicht auf dem Zettel
aufklärung tut not
wenn man nicht zu Hause ist fühlt man
sich schutzlos wenn man beklaut wird
oder man sich verläuft oder etwas
verliert und da ist dann der direkte
Kontakt mit der eigenen Polizei wichtig
da fühlen sich die Touristen
aufgehobener beruhigt einfach besser
dabei weiß Torsten Obst sehr gut wie
sich die Partytouristen hier fühlen als
junger Mann war er selbst einer von
ihnen
beim Streife gehen erinnert er sich ans
feiern hier am ballermannstrand
ich weiß noch von damals selbst als ich
mal vor 30 oder 40 Jahren hier war
damals
im Sand gesessen und wurden da bedient
von vom
Ballermann 6 mit lauter Musik und der
entsprechenden alkoholischen Getränken
das ist völlig entschärft wo er früher
selbst gefeiert hat kontrolliert er
heute als Streifenpolizist so haben sich
die Zeiten geändert Straftaten gab es
auch damals gefährliche Zonen heute vor
allem rund um den MegaPark einen der
Party Hotspots in ein paar Stunden
wimmelt es hier von Touristen und
Taschendieben wir sind hier die
Eingreiftruppe Playa und kümmern uns
unter anderem um den Ballermann 6 jetzt
ist noch sehr früh pronto sozusagen das
wird dann zum späten Abend wird's mehr
und in der Nacht noch mehr es ist alles
dabei Raub Diebstahl
Körperverletzung
Drogenkauf Drogen verkauft
drei Stunden später wird es in der
Schinkenstraße schon voller während die
fliegenden Händler einpacken bekommt das
polizei-team Verstärkung ein weiterer
deutscher Beamter aus
Nordrhein-Westfalen und auch ein
niederländischer Kollege gehen jetzt mit
während Thorsten für die deutschen
zuständig ist hilft Polizist der Ricardo
seinen holländischen Landsleuten
lass uns gleich mal eine Runde am Strand
machen wir schauen ob wir Leute sehen
die abgelenkt sind und nicht ob ihre
Sachen aufpassen und die waren wir dann
manche Täter kennen sie schon
wenn wir hier die Streifen laufen dann
haben wir ja so ein bisschen wenn man
sich sie merken kann die Gesichter von
den fahndungsblättern die wir über den
Messenger kriegen die haben wir dann
ungefähr so ein bisschen vor Augen um
die hier als Straftäter Auftreten und
die erkennt man halt auch man weiß wie
sie sich bewegen man weiß wie sie
aussehen
es wird abends auf der Promenade sammeln
sich die Partygänger
der Pegel ist noch nicht
so hoch bei den meisten ist noch etwas
ruhiger ich denke mal so in zwei drei
Stunden sieht ein bisschen anders aus
da hinten z.B am Strand und trinken dann
erstmal das gekaufte Bier aus und
wenn sie dann soweit sind und dann noch
irgendwo Laden reinkommen dann trinken
Sie noch ein bisschen weiter dann haben
sie noch zwei zwei Bier die sich noch
kaufen können die reichen dann aber auch
und dann schmeißen sie raus und dann
liegen auf dem Bürgersteig
und Thorsten Obst soll recht behalten
keine halbe Stunde später Alarm an der
Strandmauer ein deutscher Tourist ist
nicht ansprechbar
kommt jetzt ein Krankenwagen ich hoffe
wir brauchen keinen
augenscheinlich betrunkene Person hat
sich übergeben jetzt ist der Bruder
hergekommen der hat jetzt eingepackt er
kann ja auch noch laufen selbstständig
von daher aber der Einsatz ist erledigt
Notfall Nummer 2 eine junge Frau auch
eine deutsche auch auf der Strandmauer
sie hat Puls sie atmet ist alles in
Ordnung sie ist nur betrunken und müde
dafür geht man in Deutschland auch ins
Krankenhaus rufen ja das dauert aber ein
bisschen weil hier die arztfrequenz
nicht wie in Deutschland ist wo man ruft
und in 10 Minuten Rettungswagen da auf
Rettungswagen wartet man hier eine
Stunde das ist kein Arzt drauf da muss
man das Portemonnaie aufmachen die
nehmen erstmal 500 €, der deutschen
möchte ja gerne alles so wie zu Hause
haben und wenn es nicht so ist dann regt
er sich tierisch auf und das ist eben
auch die Diskussion es wird anders
gehandhabt und natürlich lassen wir ja
keinen sterben aber sie wird nicht
sterben weil alles in Ordnung ist
plötzlich wird Thorsten Obst stutzig
oh ein spezieller Geruch liegt in der
Luft
Marihuana
die Beamten finden zwei Deutsche die
sich verdächtig verhalten schnell etwas
wegwerfen
Obst war sechs Jahre lang als
Drogenfahnder im Einsatz er kennt solche
Situationen
ich gehe jetzt runter hier einen Joint
finden Sie Konsum in der Öffentlichkeit
600 ein Euro Bußgeld und
Anzeige geschrieben
nächster Tag
noch eine Spätschicht für Thorsten Obst
und sein Team
auch heute ist es heiß
und am Strand sind bereits wieder Trupps
unterwegs die fleißig dabei sind in
Stimmung zu kommen
Sonne wir
geil für Nachschub sorgen fliegende
Händler die überteuerten Sangria direkt
am Strand verkaufen manche Becher führt
10 Euro ein Geschäft das eigentlich
verboten ist
eskaliert bis zum geht nicht mehr also
dieses Eimer trinken was man so von
früher kennt man sieht ja gerade da geht
der Herr durch jetzt wird's halt so
verkaufen ne und dementsprechend ist
dann der Pegel ab 2 Uhr auch oftmals
hier so dass man merkt schon dass die
Stimmung etwas gereizter wird
Saufgelage fire Exzesse von diesem
billig Image wollen Sie hier am
Ballermann eigentlich weg
auch dafür braucht es die Polizeipräsenz
doch einige Gastronomen sehen immer noch
keine Verbesserung eher das Gegenteil
dieses Jahr ist eine Karte ganz schlimm
vielleicht ist es auch durch das
Mega-Park weil da kriegen sie ja gleich
beim ersten Getränk schon den ganzen
Liter und wenn sie dann Blasen werden
sie hinten rausgeschmissen oder ich weiß
es nicht auf jeden Fall du siehst kein
normal und sind alle betrunken und und
man sieht manchmal wenn man hier am
Strand läuft und morgen um 10 liegen sie
schon in der prallen Sonne und sind
total betrunken
wirklich jeden Meter alles von kurze
voll Geld Strafen sollen helfen die
Trinkgelage zu verhindern eine
Abschreckung die aber bisher nicht
wirklich funktioniert erzählt er da
kommen die besoffenen die sich hier alle
zugeschüttet haben die Tochter dann hier
über den Strand
kacken das kann sich anders sagen hier
in den Sand stellen sich hin und pinkeln
ins Meer
ich meine wenn sie dabei noch cool sind
ist ja in Ordnung aber meistens sind sie
nicht ruhig dabei
betrunkene die später leichte Beute für
Taschendiebe sind ich als Arbeiter hier
bekam das jeden Tag mit ist ja auch
sowas wie mein Büro hier und Taschen die
bei uns so ist halt gang und gäbe das
ist eine Mafia hier die macht das halt
wirklich professionell die packen
nüchternen Menschen wirklich auch das
Handy oder die Geldtasche raus mit dem
Messer ohne dass es mitbekommst kurz
darauf weitere Anweisungen auf Spanisch
Thorsten hör zu Spanisch sprechen und
verstehen das hat er vor Jahren zu Hause
in einem Volkshochschulkurs gelernt und
immer wieder in Urlaub haben vertieft
mehr nicht dennoch klappt die
Verständigung gut und die Chemie stimmt
auch
bis jetzt kann ich mich auf keinen Fall
beklagen weder mit 3b noch mit allen
anderen komponiere mit dem wir unterwegs
gewesen sind super aufgenommen super
zusammengearbeitet
er ist ein echt netter Kerl das macht
Spaß mit ihm zusammen zu arbeiten und
läuft
vor allem auch weil Thorsten ein
erfahrener Beamter ist 26 Jahre lang war
er bei der deutschen Autobahnpolizei hat
dabei viel erlebt das hilft ihm auch
hier
Ankunft in Palma zwei Kreuzfahrtschiffe
liegen im Hafen in der Stadt sind jetzt
viele potenzielle Opfer unterwegs Arbeit
für die polizia national
hier an der Kathedrale passiert
natürlich auch entsprechende Diebstähle
wo Tourismus ist es immer auch der
Straftäter
die große Runde entlang gehen in die
Gärten wenn das für dich okay ist
vielleicht verstecken sich da ein paar
Kriminelle und danach gehen wir zur
Kathedrale
und wir gehen jetzt den Park hoch und
dann hinten rechts zur Einstellung
die berühmte Kathedrale zieht Touristen
und Diebe gleichermaßen an
wenn die Beamten durch die engen Gassen
gehen sich die Taschendiebe die
Touristen bekommen davon nichts mit
[Musik]
vor zwei Wochen hier Handy alles weg das
ist jetzt kein Einzelfall das ist jeden
Tag dann werden sie auf einen jungen
Mann aufmerksam er hat große Ähnlichkeit
mit einem Täter der hier gestern
beobachtet wurde hast du Dokumente dabei
ich kann euch ein Foto von meinem
Ausweis zeigen bist du schon mal
verhaftet worden das habe ich jetzt
gerade initiiert weil wir gestern
während der Streifenfahrt
entfernungsfoto bekommen haben von einem
Schwarzafrikaner der als Räuber hier
unterwegs ist
der junge Mann ist nicht der gesuchte
Täter er darf weiterfahren doch wer
greift eigentlich härter durch die
spanische oder die deutsche Polizei
und es kommt aus gegenüber an gestern
hat mir ein Kollege erklärt zum
spanischer Kollege spricht die Leute
freundlich an und wenn sie entsprechend
freundlich antworten dann ist das eine
ganz normale Kontrolle wenn sie gleich
giftig werden oder sogar körperlich
werden dann ist es eine andere Kontrolle
und die werden noch nicht sofort in
Handschellen gelegt aber die Kontrolle
wird härter durchgezogen bzw man achtet
mehr auf Körpersprache und und guckt wo
geht die Aggressivität denn er ins
körperliche oder verbal und dann ist der
Kollege auch nicht mehr ganz so
entspannt dann spannt er an und dann
sieht das immer für den Außenstehenden
gerade für den Deutschen in Spanien
sieht das immer so aus als ob die
Spanier alle hart durchgreifen die
greift nicht viel hat dadurch
abends dann zurück in El Arenal wieder
füllt sich der Ballermann und die
Schinkenstraße
[Applaus]
die Stimmung steigt
noch sieht es freundlich bunt und
fröhlich aus doch Thorsten Obst und
seine Kollegen bleiben wachsam denn
gerade jetzt kann es gefährlich werden
wie gefährlich das zeigt sich auf der
Wache
hier melden sich die die gerade
überfallen wurden
mein Kollege wurde zwischen dem MegaPark
und dem Bierkönig überfallen
von fünf dunkelhäutigen
wahrscheinlich Afrikanern
einer hat ihn mit dem Messer bedroht die
kamen einfach auf uns zu und wir haben
uns wirklich gar nichts dabei gedacht
die haben uns umzingelt haben ihn
bedroht wie gesagt auch wirklich und
daraufhin hat er halt sein Geld
ausgepackt und ihnen gegeben 600 Euro
5 Minuten später noch ein deutscher
Tourist wieder ein Raub
warum gemacht gehabt und wir erfunden
herausgezogen gehabt mein Handy dann war
es weg
dann habe ich keine Chance mehr gehabt
sondern bin ich ein paar Meter noch
gelaufen bis es gemerkt habe war es
natürlich ein schöner über alle Berge
der junge Mann aus Freiburg wird morgen
wohl ohne Handy mit dem Kreuzfahrtschiff
weiterfahren
Dienstschluss für heute morgen heißt es
erstmal durchatmen
am nächsten Tag hat Thorsten Obst seinen
freien Tag
endlich Zeit für ein Telefonat mit
seinem 26-Jährigen Adoptivsohn Marvin
[Musik]
hey großer
ja es geht so es ist ganz schön
anstrengend hier wir haben echt fast
jeden Tag 35 Grad oder so das macht
körperlich macht das schon was aber ich
habe dafür wahrscheinlich wieder zwei
Kilo oder drei Kilo abgenommen
ich wollte ja heute noch den kleinen
drogenverkäufer den wollte ich heute
wegfeln aber den werde ich dann wohl
morgen erst erwischen also haben wir die
Nachtschicht auf Sonntag nachgeschoben
und machen dann morgen die Nachtschicht
ja ansonsten haben wir hier diesen
ganzen kleinen Kram ne ne siehst ja
jeden Tag heute wollte ich ein paar
Hühnchen Spieler fotografieren da
wollten sie mich gleich wieder am Sand
verbunden hier die ganzen ist schon
heavy ne aber die Kollegen freuen sich
wahrscheinlich über ein paar Fotos weil
sie die sonst nicht identifizieren
können ne ruckzucker polizia Lokal
vorbei haben sie gleich alles
eingeklappt wieder sind im Keller
gelaufen haben sie alle versteckt kaum
waren die Weg 3 Minuten später stand sie
wieder mit den Ding auf der Tür nee hier
aber
ich bin jetzt auf dem Weg ins Wasser
noch mal eine Runde ja
das werde ich heute tun morgen tschüss
[Musik]
Abkühlung im Mittelmeer eine kurze
Auszeit die der 58-Jährige genießt
abtauchen am Ballermann für ihn ein
besonderer Platz ein Strand an dem er
als Beamter schon immer mal Streife
gehen wollte und der Ort an dem als
junger Mann selbst eine gute Zeit erlebt
hat
die Nachtschicht steht an drei Teams
machen sich fertig von Mitternacht bis 6
Uhr morgens geht heute der Dienst letzte
Besprechung mit dem Einsatzleiter
lange Spezial noch nichts Besonderes es
ist wie immer alles wie jede Nacht
Alltagsgeschäft du weißt was ich meine
wir versuchen die Personen die eine Tat
verüben zu überprüfen die
Einsatzzentrale schickt uns direkt die
Meldungen per Funk und dann fahren wir
sofort dahin und schauen was los ist
aufpassen müssen und natürlich unsere
neuralgischen Punkte wieder abfahren
Schinkenstraße die ganze Playa unten
Promenade runter Respekt habe ich immer
die Tageszeit ist anders man muss ein
bisschen fokussierter sein auf das
Gegenüber
gut Menger
mehr betrunkene mehr Aggressivität
nachts sind Einsätze noch mal
gefährlicher das weiß auch Thorsten Obst
kaum sind sie losgefahren kommt der
erste Funkspruch
die Motorradstreife braucht dringend
Verstärkung
Einsatzort nahe der Schinkenstraße
zwei Minuten später sind Torsten und
sein Kollege vor Ort zwei Männer
benötigen Hilfe
so moin wir sprechen deutsch ich bin
gerade so ein schwarzer Typ und laber
kurz mit mir macht währenddessen so
meine Tasche auf nimm ein Portemonnaie
drin 100 € Weg ja okay
raus genau
schwarze Person mit einem weißen T-Shirt
und langen Hosen äh lag welche Farbe
Farbe wissen sie nicht wo das war da
drüben auf der anderen Seite oder was
war circa bei dem Mercedes da wurde der
Typ da wurde okay
also morgen zur Polizei gehen und
Anzeigen aufgeben wenn du das möchtest
oder willst
also beim ausweisen ist es ja so wenn
wir alles außer das Geld genau und das
wirst du nicht da kein Geld und bringst
du auch noch zur Polizei das macht ja
keiner okay
[Musik]
mal sehen was passiert die Nachbar die
Nacht ist noch lang
noch fünf Stunden Dienst liegen vor
ihnen
an der Strandpromenade schlägt plötzlich
ein verdeckter ermittleralarm
[Musik]
zugriff am Strand der Dieb sitzt bereits
am Boden mit Handschellen an einen
strandschirm gefesselt
von wem wurde das Internet
Thorsten versucht mit dem beklauten
Pärchen zu klären was passiert ist
der verdeckte ermittlerschildert was er
gesehen hat
unterdessen wird der Dieb in
Handschellen abgeführt die beiden
zivilkollegen haben beobachtet die
beiden sind schwimmen gegangen und
hatten ihre Sachen so unter dem hier was
er auch gerne machen
der Mann ist ihnen nicht unbekannt er
wurde schon öfter bei Straftaten
erwischt
in der Zwischenzeit kümmert sich
Thorsten Obst um die Urlauber
viele machen es den Dieben sehr einfach
ich habe gar nichts mehr bekommen aber
ich war auch relativ weit draußen noch
ich bin frisch aus mega Parkhaus
vielleicht hört man es ich war am Wasser
und dann hat die Polizei gebunden mit
Licht und hat gesagt hey komm raus komm
raus komm raus ich rausgegangen okay
Scheiße die spanische Polizei jetzt
holen sie mich weil ich spät nachts noch
im Wasser war und dann haben sie gesagt
hey die wollten dich beklauen die wollen
nicht beklauen und ist der allgemein
bekannt dass das hier mehr oder weniger
so ein Problem ist mit Taschendiebstahl
letzten Endes haben sie Gott sei Dank
den Täter geschnappt
und jetzt muss ich hier noch bleiben und
meine Initialen aufgeben und die Polizei
bespricht jetzt auf die letzten
Einzelheiten
Tobias ist dankbar der Bayer hatte Glück
ich habe alles und nichts ist weg
dank dem netten Herrn
2:30 Uhr die Nachtschicht geht weiter
die Beamten haben heute gut zu tun
für uns für die Polizei hier ist spielt
sich alles draußen ab heute wieder ganz
besonders viele betrunkene
und dann Streitereien und ähnliche
Sachen und eben die Diebstähle direkt um
die MegaPark MegaPark sind viele Leute
und wo viele Leute sind sind viele Täter
keine Stunde später der nächste Fall
wieder ein diebstahlversuch am Strand
diesmal hat eine verdeckte Ermittlerin
alles beobachtet und die Sachen der
Touristen gesichert aber der Täter
konnte entfliehen
die ahnungslose Touristin und ihr Freund
kommen jetzt erst aus dem Wasser beide
brauchen etwas länger um die Situation
zu verstehen
ein Moment sag ihr sie bekommt ihre
Sachen gleich zurück wir müssen nur
alles für die Anzeige auflisten
naja es war ein versuchter Diebstahl
versuchter Raub was auch immer und
deswegen wird es aufgenommen wer hat
denn hier versucht was zu klauen die
Kollegin steht hier in Zivil und hat den
Typen gesehen wie er eure Sachen klauen
wollte ach so was haben wir denn geklaut
bekommen ihr habt nichts geklaut
bekommen aber es ist genauso eine
Straftat eine versuchter Diebstahl ist
auch eine Straftat hier in genauso wie
bei uns wenn ich dir zu Hause was
wegnehmen will dann ist auch versucht
sie ist Polizistin und hat es gesehen
und hat den Täter Ding wollte ihn
dingfest machen und der die beiden
Motorradfahrer sind jetzt hinter ihm her
versuchen ihn im Parkplatz zu fahren
während die Beamten den Dieb im Park
suchen will Polizist Thorsten
herausfinden ob doch etwas gestohlen
wurde
hast du gesagt 100 € und wieso hast du
jetzt noch weiß ich nicht
dann der Funkspruch die Kollegen haben
den Dieb im Park gefasst
wenn ich das richtig gesehen habe haben
sie aber die Motorradfahrer Kollegen
haben ihn eingefangen und wir haben
jetzt gerade hier als Deutsche sind die
personalaufnahme gemacht
zwei Verhaftungen in einer Nacht ein
Erfolg als Final
losgekommen
das ist ein Wiederholungstäter
beide Diebe von heute kennen wir bereits
die verdeckten Ermittler beobachten sie
und sobald sie merken dass sie etwas
klauen wollen schlagen Sie zu
so wie ihr das jetzt hier gesehen habt
während der Täter auf die Wache muss
gehen weitere ahnungslose Touristen
Baden genau darauf warten die
Taschendiebe aber auch die verdeckten
Ermittler ein Katz und Mausspiel wie
jede Nacht am Ballermann
[Musik]
wird es jetzt richtig voll die Bart
schließen und die Touristen gehen zum
Schwimmen und lassen all ihre Sachen
Portemonnaies Taschen einfach alles am
Strand das ist die Gelegenheit für Diebe
jetzt zwischen 3 und 5 Uhr ist das für
uns die problematischste Zeit da haben
wir gut zu tun
vielleicht der nächste Funkspruch wieder
hat ein Strand die zugeschlagen die
Opfer deutsche Touristinnen
[Musik]
Geld alles scheißegal Handy ist weg und
das Geld ist möglicherweise Weg gibt
viel gewesen
schon früher nach Hause gegangen und
dann braucht man dein Handy um 15 Uhr
heute
dann kam ein ich glaube ein männliche
Person und hat meine Bauchtasche nur
weggenommen wir haben nämlich immer so
Leute so angeschaut und geguckt so ja
gehen die unsere Sachen die nie weg und
deswegen haben wir auch gerufen weil wir
es halt gesehen haben dass er so in der
Nähe von so Sachen und dann auch gewöhnt
hat das ist ja noch relativ viel los
dachten wir das passiert halt nicht ganz
so schnell was muss ich denn da machen
normalerweise auf jeden Fall eine
Anzeige aufgeben
Thorsten übersetzt das Gespräch seinem
spanischen Kollegen
sie würde morgen zur Wache gehen und
meine Anzeige zu machen nein
dann ist auch dieser Einsatz erledigt
Fazit der Nachtschicht viele der
Diebstähle wären vermeidbar gewesen wenn
Touristen die Warnungen der Polizei
ernst nehmen würden aber sie machen
immer die gleichen Fehler wie Thorsten
Obst nüchtern feststellt leichtgläubig
leicht betrunken
wenn ich sehe was sie alles dabei haben
das schleppe ich auch mit mir nicht rum
wenn ich rausgehe also ich bin dann
immer minimal
ausgerüstet aber die haben alles dabei
die Vertrauen im Hotelzimmer
wahrscheinlich nicht oder ich weiß es
nicht haben also ihr ganzes Leben hier
in der Tasche ist dann ist es weg alle
Papiere dabei Führerscheine
Krankenkassenkarte das brauche ich am
Strand nicht wenn ich am schwimmen gehe
5:30 Uhr Dienst Ende Schluss für heute
nächster Tag der Betrieb an der Playa
geht weiter Sonne Strand sorglose
Touristen und Kriminelle die Ausschau
nach Opfern halten nur für Thorsten Obst
ist der Dienst am Ballermann in vier
Tagen zu Ende statt Strand heißt es dann
wieder Innendienst in Braunschweig sein
Fazit es gibt hier zu viele Täter die
auch immer wieder nachrücken selbst wenn
einer mal länger ins Gefängnis geht oder
abgeschoben wird es gibt einfach zu
viele das ist aber in Deutschland genau
das gleiche
abends strömen wieder Touristen an den
Ballermann auch heute sind die Beamten
im Einsatz sorgen für Sicherheit mitten
im Getümmel zwischen Feiernden
fröhlichen Menschen in Urlaubsstimmung
[Musik]